Let's have some fun with physics.
As soon as I finish writing this short
piece of text,
I'm going to delete the document that
contains it from my computer.
The question is,
when I erase these 320,000
bits of information,
where do they go?
Thermodynamics tells us that matter and
energy can never be destroyed,
only transferred.
Well,
this goes for information to when I
erase something from my computer,
it's not destroyed but transferred into
heat.
That's why laptops get hot.
That's why computers need fans to cool
them down.
This law,
the information can never be destroyed,
holds true everywhere in the universe
except one place.
Black hole in the 19 seventies,
Steven Hawking showed us that black
holes actually radiate super hot energy
from their event horizons.
The place where everything even light is
irrevocably do.
This meant crucially that black holes
get smaller and smaller and evaporate
over time,
eventually disappearing altogether.
This is like the universe erasing its
own word document,
except for what we've already said can
never be destroyed.
Information looks like here actually is
and the information paradox was born.
Scientists have a love hate relationship
with paradoxes over the years.
Many have tried to solve the information
paradox and we'll talk about a few here,
but first,
Jacob Bekenstein knowing that he could
never actually read the information
inside a black hole Bekenstein resolve
to figure out how much hidden
information otherwise known as entropy.
A given black hole actually contained.
Now,
you'd imagine that the amount of entropy
in a black hole would equal the volume
of that black hole,
like the amount of coffee in a coffee
mug equals the volume of that Mug,
but Bekenstein found that in the case of
black holes,
the amount of hidden information inside
is not equal to the volume,
but the area of the event horizons
surface.
That's pretty crazy.
This means that when inflammation
approaches a black hole,
it gets plastered onto the event horizon
surface,
like dots on a super hot basketball,
but there's a problem here and I think
it's time to bring matthew mcconaughey
into the equation.
At the end of the movie,
interstellar spoilers,
Matthew mcconaughey goes into a black
hole when he hits the event horizon.
He seems to be fine.
There's nothing really surprising about
that.
We know that eventually mcconaughey is
going to get ripped to shreds by the
intense gravity of the black hole
eventually being smushed into the
singularity,
but we sort of know that when you cross
the event horizon of a large black hole,
you probably wouldn't feel anything like
the film shows,
but how does this square with what we
just said,
that all information approaching a black
hole gets hot glue gunned to its event
horizon.
The answer is here.
This is a stereogram.
You might remember them from grade
school.
A Two d image that when looked at for
long enough reveals a hidden picture
that seems to rise off the plane,
otherwise known as a Hologram.
Notice that the three d info appears
highly scrambled into Dick.
This is what's happening to Matthew
mcconaughey.
What he travels past the event horizon
of a black hole.
Everything that happens inside the black
hole is essentially a hologram of the
information encoded on it's two d
surface mcconaughey would move past the
event horizon feeling alright?
Alright,
alright.
But an observer from outside would see
him incinerated and spread across the
surface as particles.
The crazy thing is that both
perspectives would be correct.
According to physicists,
Leonard Susskind,
this may be the case for the entire
universe,
the three dimensional space we live in
and moving every everyday may be in
effect a Hologram of a lower dimensional
universe.
I'll be it a perfect holiday.
This is called the holographic
principle.
It doesn't mean that the universe is a
dream or an illusion or anything like
that,
but it is as genuinely revolutionary and
idea as relativity was to Tony and
physics.
We don't know why it works,
but every time we try to quantify the
amount of information in an enclosed
space,
it's always equal to the surface area of
that space.
I guess it just goes to show that once
again,
the universe is not intuitive to the
human mind,
but that doesn't mean once again,
we can't figure it out.
Hey everybody,
thanks for watching and thank you to the
patriotic patrons.
Those 64 of you out there and I was
bowled over by the support for this
channel.
You can all consider yourself as part of
a special nerd writer club now,
and I have a lot of really cool things
planned for you.
Google hangouts treats you,
you've known you've no idea it's going
to be fun.
Um,
first things first.
I'm going to collect all of your emails
so that I can send out a weekly or
biweekly newsletter,
the Patriot on patrons,
uh,
where you can hear about what's going to
come up.
If you want to be a patriot patron for
the nerd writer,
you can pledge as little as $1 to this
channel.
If you pledge a little bit more like $5,
you could get a special nerd writer mug.
Oh my God,
I was.
I was so pumped when these came and you
have no idea.
There's only one left,
but if there's a demand,
I'll definitely order more and get more
swag and things like that.
And it's just,
it's just,
it's just great.
As always,
I'm going to be in comments talking
about the holographic principle.
Thank you for watching again and I'll
see you next time.